ah
i'm sorry sean there's a lot of like no
no no make no apologies i apologize make
no apologies my behavior no this is not
how my mother raised
[Music]
me what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by simulu he's the
actor of course stars in 2021's highest
grossing box office film shang chi and
the legend of the 10 rings which you can
currently find streaming on disney plus
today though it's the legend of the ten
wings howling fair i guess only time
will tell simu welcome to the show i
knew that was the only reason i was on
the show
and and fair enough we got the punt out
nice and early i'm glad um
kind of wondering why i agreed to this
no no it's such an honor it's such an
honor to be here sean thank you for for
having me
i can already smell it and it's already
up my nose
[Music]
perfect
cheers cheers
great
okay
all right
what have you got for me
[Laughter]
so shangji in the legend of the 10 rings
it features a hollywood hall of fame
ensemble of action movie legends from
the matrix's bill pope to members of
jackie chan's stunt team to your co-star
tony leung what was the most challenging
or gnarly wire work scene to pull off
director destin daniel [ __ ] described
the runaway bus that's in the act one
fight sequence as being a claustrophobic
barf machine
that's fair that's fair that was a
gnarly sequence i mean we we took two
san francisco mini buses we shipped them
to sydney australia we gutted them put
them up on airbags and gimbals was
basically like imagine a disneyland ride
right so every day you go to work you
get this like
ladder
you walk up into this um suspended bus
like 50 feet in the air and then it just
starts twisting and moving and um i must
have like banged my knees and shins and
elbows and forehead on um like every
single possible appendage of that bus so
the last take that i did i think we had
already gotten the shot so of course
it's always that last one that um you
shouldn't do that ends up being the one
that you get injured on but i was like
let me do one more let me do one more i
can totally do it better i remember
being like i'm gonna give it the like
just the best baseball slide so i went
straight in and there was this little
tiny
piece jutting out of the the roof of the
bus and for some reason my kneecap went
straight into it and i was i was down
and out for uh for a hot sack
[Music]
i like it shawn is that all you got
don't don't
just say that that's a that's a bad idea
the two wings in confidence you know i
never get sick of that
so early in your career you produce
starred and wrote a handful of short
films many of which i was able to find i
was able to track down on the wong fu
productions youtube channel okay what is
it that you find sacred about shorts
because i think for a lot of people the
annual academy award nominations that
represents the entirety of what they
know about the art form mm-hmm
this is the big thing about short films
is that they're affordable yeah but when
you're a 10 000 budget exactly exactly
when you're a starving artist and you're
and you're just trying to look for ways
to create content try to get things
going um you can't necessarily fund an
entire feature film and so you do a
short oftentimes it's a proof of concept
or just something that you can show off
to be like hey this is a calling card i
want more opportunities to do this maybe
on a bigger scale but uh i first saw
wong fu i was in high school it was like
youtube was just starting to be a thing
first of all there are a bunch of
asian-american filmmakers who
you know at a time when those
opportunities didn't exist in the system
they went out and
made their own luck they just went out
and they were like screw it i'm going to
create and people are going to watch it
and
that's exactly what happened and for so
many of us for millions of
you know diasporic asian youth that was
the only representation that we had for
a really really long time so i have all
the respect in the world for those guys
i you know continue to want to work with
them and they're they're the best
i can keep this one down
but i'm not letting myself get
overconfident
i feel it building mm-hmm and then i
feel um
it's settling like i don't need to go to
the boba yet i'm the topic of the boba
though
you know uh
boba guys mutual friends of ours yes yes
came through so we have two of them so
this is the jasmine one that you like
right you like the green jasmine love me
some jasmine milk tea yup and then this
one they actually made for me they call
it the antidote with like a horchata
sort of base to it okay so they actually
made this for me on like the spicy food
yeah yeah you want to try it
[Music]
oh yeah
oh yeah it's soothing
it's soothing
so before becoming a marvel superhero
know that your first job out of college
was at a big four accounting firm
is there anything that you learned being
an accountant that's actually helped you
now that you're depositing disney checks
i learned that i was a terrible
accountant my error rate was so high
like literally every spreadsheet that i
ever sent in i would get it back
immediately and it would just be marked
completely in red and my supervisors
were just like
i don't know what to do with you like i
don't and
you know i would like check my work i
would like you know i i obviously didn't
want to be bad at my job but um i just i
just couldn't do it sometimes sometimes
it's just things aren't meant to be in
the universe and thank god for that
because because you had a different
calling exactly and then speaking of
those odd jobs to start from college
brochures to billboards to the covers of
textbooks where is the strangest place
that you've ever seen your getty stock
images pop up in real life
i saw myself on uh
on the wall of a karate dojo
but you know but but we didn't do any
karate photos in the in in the stock
shoot so it was actually it was a photo
of i think me doing zumba
um so i was like in this pose where i
was smiling and doing one of these one
of these swings and it was in a it was
in a martial arts dojo so not great also
somewhat ironically i was on the cover
of an accounting textbook i think it was
like quickbooks or something and i was
like the i
i don't know
i
i wouldn't trust me to teach anybody
anything about accounting
[Music]
okay here we go
those calientes
how many wings
would you say you've had over the course
of your entire
hotline career
well you know the the accounting
conversation is actually a nice segue
into this kind of question because you
know
we're probably
230 episodes in right
10 wings an episode that put me squarely
over 2
300 wings that i've eaten for the
internet's amusement over the years so
do you still enjoy wings outside of work
or has it nah you know there's a couple
things that have ruined ruined it for me
first off it feels like work you know
like that kind of thing plus i've eaten
a lot of them so it's like kind of the
last thing that i want to eat and then
the other side of it is like you know i
go to a restaurant or something and this
is nice i'm not complaining but it's
like somebody'll come out of the kitchen
like oh these are for you and then
there's like wings or like a friend's
coming into town and they're like
where's the best place to get wings like
you know everybody has kind of like
you're the wing guy i've been type cast
in acting terms as like though my wing
guy
so i think you sort of like start to
then resent wings over time or something
that's so funny that you say that
because because my fear in in this movie
and and its success and of course has
been very successful and very happy
about it is that
it will perpetuate this kind of
narrative
that only you know the asian people can
only lead martial arts movies which is
not true right but but of course it's
something that you know
i don't want people to constantly come
up to me and be like hey
i bet i could i bet i could kick it all
right what do you think you know um
so so i get that i feel that yeah you
know wanting to you know be known for
other things exactly already connecting
already can you sure on wing four but as
long as people keep watching on youtube
i'll keep throwing them down
he says
[Music]
this one's a little bit of a step up
mm-hmm
[Music]
fill that one this one will grow it'll
bellow a little bit but while it's doing
that i'll set you up because we have
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham we're doing deep
dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context okay i know that you're a star
wars die-hard do you have an all-time
favorite jedi it's got to be qui-gon
jinn
let me quiegon jan i feel like look i
don't know how deep you are in star wars
i'm going i'm just following you you're
following me yeah all right so so this
whole idea of like the jedi during the
old republic
just feels like you know if you
you look at those council scenes where
everyone's so like stuck up they're all
just like uh
uh these are the rules you know we don't
we don't ever break the rules and
there's like no
and and by the way very hypocritical too
because the jedi are supposed to like
not want power they're like we have no
thirst for power we know and there's
literally like
a council that oversees everything
that's like in the highest part of
coruscant so anyway
anyway i just love that qui-gon is like
a bit of a maverick like he doesn't care
he's like sorry i'm gonna i'm gonna
train this kid and ultimately that kid
is gonna grow up to become darth vader
and overthrow the entire republic but
still you gotta admire the guy that can
see through the hypocrisy of the jedi
order right they think they're the good
guys they're like oh yeah we're so good
but but like
you know
really we're the instruments of their
own demise in a way sorry i've already
no i love it you get me on a star wars
tangent and i'm telling you that i will
show you my true colors
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was involuntary
all right keep uh uh
that's right you know that's why it was
wise though to not get too far out in
front because yeah hot sauce
it catches you no you're right you're
right when you least expect it okay
[Music]
this is number six six all right senor
lechuga
yeah and there it is
it's arrived
[Music]
so connecting the dots looking back
would seem like your place in the mcu is
basically destiny in fact in your recent
snl monologue you talked about how you
played spider-man at kids birthday
parties to make ends meet as an actor
were you ever goaded into breaking
character by like a problem by like a
problem child or drunken adult
drunken
drunken adult no because they generally
stayed out of my way because all they
wanted to do was day drink with the
other adults
that's kind of the whole point of having
a birthday party spiderman it's to like
babysit your kids so that you can just
go and and do whatever
when you're doing these birthday parties
you got to pay attention to the age
right for some whatever freaking reason
some parents will book a spider-man for
like an eight-year-old party
and when you see it you're like oh this
is not gonna be good because
eight-year-olds aren't gonna be into
that they are they're already starting
to like understand and internalize that
like movies aren't real
and so when you show up with like a 25
spider-man suit that like basically your
boss got from a target somewhere like
that's not going to be enough for them
that took a while that like percolated
for a little bit yeah it kind of yeah it
has that sort of volcanic sort of
eruption to it but you don't know when
it's going to go off
but do you think it might have primed
the pipes for the next one
[Laughter]
um
you're the expert sean you tell me i
think you just you just swing you just
swing big you know let's do it so this
one is the buddha of fire here in the
seventh spot okay
[Music]
nice big one we're not shying away from
the bites here
yeah
we've all made it so far
i'm gonna have some jasmine all right
yeah you know i don't think we need to
break out the antidote just yeah
right you might be onto something here
[Music]
so recently you received a hero's
welcome at the toronto premiere of
chongqi actually having that massive
welcome back billboard in the middle of
downtown what's the institutional
significance of square one for a young
person growing up in mississauga
my god that's deep cut um
square one man oh god i'm impressed
square one first of all square one is is
by by um by sheer size the the largest
mall in ontario that was the place to
hang out especially if you're underage
you just hang out the mall you watch
movies one of my first jobs ever i was a
model
oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah like shirt off in front of the
store so no not in front of the store
per se just just like inside taking in
the fumes and uh folding clothes and
pretending like i was a model i remember
too because like when i was in high
school like some of my friends would be
like oh like i got scouted or like one
of my friends got scouted and that's you
know apparently a thing that would
happen yeah they're like oh you look
like a cool kid like do you want to work
it out
and so i remember i wanted to be hot and
cool so bad i would i would go uh to the
to the stores and i would just hang out
waiting to get waiting to get scouted
and i would like try to do my hair and
like you know never happen and so i was
so desperate that i i literally just
came in with a resume and i was like hey
guys i would love to
and you know and and um the manager at
the time like kind of took pity on me
and he was like why don't you show up to
this group interview
i got hired and i ended up um ended up
being an abercrombie model proudest
moment of my life
not sure if you've heard of this next
one before
the bomb be honest i seem to i think
i've
i think i've seen it before on this show
yeah
yeah okay so this is that one okay
let's do it let's do it let's do it you
can see it you know what i'm not going
to do though i'm not going to go here
well this is you want me to go here
because this is what really sets people
off i'm i'm on to you all right come on
to you well let's see
okay let's see i'm ready
[Music]
oh god
oh god
oh my god yeah
antidote yep i told you i told you it'd
be right back
can i hold
i give it a good shot
only two more to go two more to go it's
immediately so much
yeah and it doesn't stop
but it doesn't stop
i think there's a little bit of a
cumulative effect in it all uh-huh hits
the wall right here i need the eyes yeah
so you said in your gq essentials piece
that representation matters not only in
the movies but also in america's snack
aisles what are three asian snacks you
think should be
more widely available in convenience and
gas stations across the land and why
[Music]
shrimp chips
hello panda you know panda cookies with
like a little bit of filling on the
inside yeah
that hits so fast yeah yeah and then
just careful around your eyes just
careful around your eyes
then it just grows it doesn't stop it's
a relentless sauce
it's like getting your heart broken for
the first time
you think there's no never hurt you
think you'll never get out of it
and then you just kind of just kind of
stay with it yeah you just stick with it
you know find yourself a nice friend
exactly we'll support you through it and
i'm right here i'm right here with you
i'm right here with you you wake up and
you're like
hey
it doesn't hurt as much
but we're not there yet okay
you want some of this yeah yeah
[Music]
antidote my ass
andrew andrew
he's on set andrew
what is this the antidote to
whoa
i'm sorry sean there's a lot of no no
make no apologies i apologize make no
apologies my behavior no this is not
getting a little bit
a lot of space on this show
so this next one
is hellfire's cranked that's the one
with the crazy face
i don't i don't necessarily look at that
and think oh i just need to put this on
my food yeah yeah yeah put this inside
me please um
okay
okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
pain
pain
but incredible perseverance on display
so recently you covered men's health and
for good reason since i know that you've
been tirelessly training at the ck gym
that you recently built with your
friends
yes yes the secret okay
okay
you have a very aggressive sort of
high-flying style of play what is the
key to a hard-driven spike
oh very good question uh timing is more
important than pure vertical so
you know
if you have a good setter he's setting
at a a really kind of like nice height
where the ball is nice and floaty and uh
you want to basically watch for the apex
i want to watch out for the apex of of
that set and once that ball starts to
begin its downward trajectory that's
when you want to launch yourself in the
air so that you're making contact with
the ball at the highest possible
place you want to keep that ball in
front of you you don't want to spike it
too far over
because that just like you know that's
not where you're going to get your power
from you want to hit it like right here
and then you want to give the wrist nice
little snap as you're making contact
with the ball so
apex you go up you're kind of targeting
it with your with your non-dominant hand
and then
you kind of snake out snap that wrist
and uh
and then that's uh that's that's spike's
town baby and then watch the bodies hit
the floor all right
we've done it
we're here
it's almost over
[Music]
sean come on we've made it this far
okay how much how much do we put here
well be careful because i can already
see that it's got some uh
it's got some liquid action yeah yeah
that's too much already there you go
okay a little dab a little dab okay well
dab
that's good that's good i'm doing this
for you sean
i'm honored i'm humbled
shall we shall we cheers cheers
it's been fun yeah that's a lie
let's go
[Music]
impressive very impressive
considering
whoa
okay we have to it's the last one
what kind of example are we setting for
the children right right if we don't do
this
kids try this at home
this is a metaphor
don't actually try it at all it's a
metaphor
it's a metaphor for perseverance
it's a metaphor for pursuing your dreams
[Music]
as a metaphor
for staying strong in the face of
adversity
and uh
and you know what else the good news is
semu that we have conquered the wings of
death today and the even better news is
there's only one more question before
you send we send you on your way with
the to go pint of ice cream
a lot has been made about your totally
coincidental but prognostic tweet about
joining the marvel universe if that
helped to manifest your current reality
what is the next speak it into existence
thing
that is on your spice soaked brain right
now
is it a dream to return
lx4
oh my god
maybe a debut album you guys
now i have to now i have to explain it i
have to
i have to
in middle school
myself
and three friends of mine started a boy
band
called lx4
were we good no
did we ever go anywhere with our talents
absolutely not
but uh boy did we
act like we were
[Music]
uh
nsync incarnate
we were the jonas brothers that never
were unfortunately
we had one song called for you and um i
will not play it for you
but you know what semu the lx4 legacy it
lives on today in hot ones and with this
amazing performance against the wings of
death
and now there's nothing left to do at
long last but roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life hell yeah all
right guys look
the shanxi and the legend of the 10
rings
you can stream it on disney plus and get
the blu-ray you can get the hd blu-ray
you get the 8k
special edition blu-ray with the
the commentary in the deleted scenes
follow your dreams
persevere through adversity
and when life gives you the tenth wing
with a dab
you take that dab and you finish the
whole damn wing all right
all right
good talk
thank you
[Music]
perfect thank you
you're free to go
awesome awesome
i appreciate the deep cuts man oh yeah
thank you we got you we have to for simu
i literally was so spot i didn't even
mention you i am actually working on
music right now oh really it's too late
it's too late it's done
there's always a bonus scene there's
always a bonus scene
what's that for we're just gonna pack up
your sauces you're gonna get to take
them off with
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans and there are many
reasons to be a monthly hot one
subscription box subscriber but if you
ask me at the top of that list
is the fact that you get to try things
first before anybody and that's what's
happening in december because in the
december subscription box for the first
time ever
hot sauce for kids that's right hot
sauce for kids i'd like to introduce you
to hot ones junior the green
this sauce is a super tasty flavor clash
of green apples sweet banana warm
jalapeno lets kids sort of experience
the hot ones tradition but at the
foothills of mount scoville it's perfect
for french fries chicken nuggets the
things that kids love get your hands on
hot ones junior be the first to try it
in the december subscription box
heatness.com.com to get your hands on
the green hot ones junior before anyone
else
it's super tasty and it's a hot sauce
for kids
[Music]
you